There is something else that makes me deeply angry,
is what I saw when
of the next plenary floor in the European Parliament,
you will have read in the middle of the agricultural fair
where 1 debate will be
organized on driver's license reform,
and when I looked at the content of this text,
I was deeply scandalized,
I am the grandson of a farmer,
to see that he wanted to make it mandatory
installation of a driver's license
to drive tractors,
which today is not the case,
uh, in France,
and when you are over 16 years old and you work in 1
school operation,
we have the right to drive tractors.
He wants to set even more standards and in particular
the passage of a driving license for tractors.
I say that the Union
European Union may have other priorities
than to put oil on the fire
precisely on the issue of farmers and that
it is perhaps necessary to review this
driver's license reform.